what I always say people just do it well
I don't say that Nike does but you don't
know do you know where Nike got that
logo yeah the logo no there's not the
swish I'm sorry where they got that
tagline just do it no it is one of you
is it you and a TED talk it's one of the
most horrific stories you'll ever hear
oh it's terrible and they do not talk
about it very often are we going to talk
about it right here right now get a
horrific storm Larry Gilmore remember
Gary Gilmore
Gary Gilmore Gary Gilmore was the person
shot in a firing squad right he's the
one that um that Norman mailer wrote the
book about he also claimed to be to tie
it all together Houdini's
um great nephew or something he wasn't
he was alive why was Gary Gilmore uh
shot at by a firing he was he was put to
death and he insisted on it being a
firing squad and there were lots of
constitutional whether that was his
right he was the last person the last uh
American sadly not the last person put
to death by us right by by firing squad
and what was he charged with uh I think
he's a murderer
um it's not the most interesting part of
the story he had he had Capital guns he
had capital crimes okay and what year
was this oh Jesus that would have been
before Nike obviously 70s oh so Adidas
were already I want to know what he was
charged with well we're gonna put the
idea is
you are going to get to the most
interesting part but I'm a True Crimes
fan I want to know what he was charged
with you can't be a True Crimes fan can
you really yes
but you know you mean literature about
them right she actually loves this
happening she loves the crime I don't
know Fortune crime podcasts and stuff
like that so like the stories that go
along with it what was he I did uh oh
yes right there I did a thing uh
Off-Broadway years ago called exonerated
where uh we talked about people who had
been on death row and been exonerated
and I played the part of one of the uh
one of the characters it was really hard
to to read about it and study it and
you're leaving out the most important
part that became the seat belt
uh offenders
um
and Gary Gilmore
his last words
as he stood in front of the firing no no
where just do it just do it no way
that's not where it came from that's not
where you're from and in a ill-conceived
interview
the person at on a Nike that came up
with that said he was inspired by Gary
Gilmore as it was a really catchy phrase
you know what's funny too because you
mentioned that phrase all the time
that's like your go-to she's telling you
the truth if anybody asked me advice I
say My Credo in life my philosophy in
life is Nikes just do it and now you
just ruined mine all you just say is
Gary Gilmore's
it's Gary you just say my daughter she
loves crying and people killing people
and I love people being killed for
killing people so I'm with Gary okay
then it's not what I mean I only read up
I only read it One Source look up Nike
Gary Gilmore type in those well we do
and well type in 19 Gary Gilmore
she's not Mandela it's not conspiracy no
because the Gary Gilmore which I did
just look up on Twitter said let's do it
just do it how murderer Gary Gilmore's
final words the Manning firing squad
officers pull their trigger inspired
Nike's famous slogan almost exactly what
I said and it's in the Daily Mail it's
not in like The Inquirer or something
it's the Daily Mail
[Music]